on her last day as international
criminal court prosecutor
fatou bensouda requested authorization
to formally
investigate philippine president rodrigo
duterte for possible crimes
against humanity it's a farewell move
that families of many of those killed in
the so-called
war on drugs are grateful for
since 2018 duterte's policy has been
subjected to preliminary examination
the international criminal court has
been analyzing a large amount of public
information in addition to the
complaints and supplementary reports
submitted by international rights groups
and lawyers here representing families
prosecutor bensouda says her examination
found that
extrajudicial killings in the
philippines have mostly been state
sanctioned
since duterte took office as president
in 2016
thousands of filipinos have been killed
the government puts the number
at around seven thousand but rights
groups believe
deaths in police-related anti-drug
operations
may reach nearly thirty thousand it
brings the message that from the top
down
whether directly or indirectly you
participate
golden induce justify encourage
cover up in whatever way you may
be liable the philippines has formally
withdrawn as a signatory to the rome
statute
and the government has repeatedly said
it will not take part in any icc
proceedings
the decision to move forward into a
formal investigation
stage is legally erroneous politically
motivated but what is clear now
is that a unilateral withdrawal will not
prevent the chamber
from continuing to look into possible
crimes
he has been belittling this institution
for so long
but what we believe it just
masks his insecurity
actually deep down i think he believes
that the iccs
as an institution has the capacity to
enforce
its decisions the government says it
regrets the actions taken
by prosecutor ben souda and that the
justice department here
continues to reinvestigate cases of
fatalities
in drug related operations but for the
families of the victims
the icc move provides a sliver of hope
that there is an alternative venue for
justice
especially they say when their own
justice system in the country
has failed them jamella allendogen al
jazeera
manila